hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and we just got
confirmation that the heroes worst fears
came true not only are the villains
recruiting more powerful allies to their
cause but they are also in possession of
the quirk equivalent to a freaking nuke
i knew that this would happen i've been
talking about it for a while and now
it's here and it changes everything the
odds of winning in the final showdown
are now heavily in the villain's favor
this is really really bad for the heroes
so let's get into it if you guys enjoy
our pokenohiro content and you want us
to keep it going just leave a quick like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps with the youtube algorithm and
if you're new to anime uproar or maybe
you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications finally this video will
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the previous three chapters
were titled how we all became heroes
parts one through three and those
chapters dealt with class 1a coming to
terms with the aoyama traitor reveal and
with all the heroes preparing their next
move against the villains we know that
izawa has a top secret plan a plan that
involves class 1a and aoyama in
particular but we still don't know all
the details what we do know is that the
heroes want to split all the major
villains up so that they can deal with
them one by one instead of all at the
same time it seems that dobby in
particular is a major target for this
plan because dobby is so emotionally
invested in getting revenge on endeavour
that baiting him to come out of hiding
even as the other villains continue to
hide shouldn't be too difficult on top
of that we know that deku and other
students are getting some brand new gear
thanks to mei hatsume and at the end of
the previous chapter we saw that
spider-man shinso is also going to be
involved in all of this the latest
chapter is called how we all became
heroes minus one and it deals with what
the villains have been doing to prepare
for the final showdown this chapter
confirmed the game-changing twist that
we've all been waiting for a twist that
i've been predicting for well over a
year the chapter begins with toga
visiting her childhood home which lies
abandoned and in ruins hateful graffiti
calling her a demon or covering the
walls and toga recalls how even her own
parents gave up on her and called her a
demon child she was called creepy and a
deviant by her parents and pretty much
everyone else and no one would ever
accept her creepier tendencies such as
her fascination with blood and violence
toga then recounts a disturbing
recurring dream involving a sparrow but
i'm not even gonna get into that stuff
here not only is it something that
totally creeps me out but it's also the
kind of thing that our youtube overlords
would definitely not want me to talk
about
that said one thing is clear from all of
this himiko toga really is someone who
is psychologically disturbed and someone
whose urges are incompatible with a
functional society toga isn't just
someone who is misunderstood and who
decided to rebel against society because
society mistreated her i mean yes
society did treat her harshly but at the
same time she really is psychotic and
dangerous no society can function if it
tolerates someone like toga being
allowed to physically hurt people and
animals for her own amusement so that
means that toga wouldn't fit in in any
functional society she is not just some
misunderstood and relatable villain who
happened to grow up on the wrong side of
the tracks or something like that she
really is someone who fundamentally
deviates from everything that a normal
society is required to uphold in order
to function and it is interesting to
encounter such a villain face to face
she is someone who is just so radically
different from what we consider a normal
person to be that she simply can't
co-exist with normal people within the
same society okay i totally understand
your point
however
as the editor i can always do this and
prove that she is the best girl one
thing is clear from all of this himiko
toga really is someone who is
misunderstood and who decided to rebel
against society because society
mistreated her she really is a relatable
villain who happened to grow up on the
wrong side of the tracks and it is
interesting to encounter such a villain
face to face
anyway dobby then shows up unannounced
and he is surprised to see that someone
like toga would be sentimental enough to
visit her old childhood home toga just
brushes it off as curiosity but this
scene does hint at the fact that toga
has something resembling normal human
sentimentality at the same time though
whatever her sentiments may be toga's
worldview is still radically different
from the average person dobby asks toga
if she is ready to finally end this
pathetic world that rejected her and she
responds that she can't go back now
dobby is happy to hear this and in a
grand symbolic gesture he burns down
toga's old childhood home he says that
the world doesn't care whether they
smile or cry it will just continue
spinning and the sun will rise again
tomorrow impartial to everything that's
happening so if that's the case and the
world will just keep spinning regardless
of whether they smile or cry or do
nothing at all they might as well have a
good laugh dobby then reveals that
before machia tore down the villain
mansion he managed to grab a sample of
twice's blood toga now has that blood in
her possession and since twice as
someone she held a deer she will now be
able to use twice's ultimate power the
infamous overpowered and terrifying sad
man's parade and this is
massive this changes everything ever
since twice's death i've been
speculating that toga might have a
sample of his blood and that she may be
planning to avenge him by using none
other than sad man's parade we all know
how dangerous sad man's parade is we saw
it in action against the meta liberation
army and we know that the heroes were so
afraid of it that hawks made the
decision to kill twice rather than risk
giving him the opportunity to use it
again and yet i knew that after toga's
quirk awakened it was only a matter of
time before she also used sad man's
parade i was so convinced of it that
when i made a video last year ranking
the strongest multiple quirk users in
mha i included toga on the list ahead of
another character whom many consider to
be way stronger than toga i got a lot of
heat for that in the comments but i was
so sure that toga would end up having
the ability to use sad man's parade that
i took it as a given and i counted it as
one of her abilities i'm glad that
gamble paid off because some people
definitely thought i was crazy after i
made that video and if you want to check
it out i will link that video in the
description but yeah i know i've said
this already but this confirmation that
toga can now use sad man's parade is a
massive game changer with so many heroes
and hero students now located within the
ua school grounds toga can use sad man's
parade to surround all of ua and storm
it using an endless army of clones the
ua may have an incredible new security
system but if anything can challenge
that security system it is sad man's
parade and if toga can ever find a way
to sneak into the ua grounds by
transforming it to someone else first
then it's really game over if sadman's
parade ever gets past the ua security
system that's a wrap if the villains can
take uae and all of the heroes and hero
students who are currently based there
they will break the back of the already
struggling and short-staffed heroes toga
with sad man's parade could be the key
to a villain victory sad man's parade
plus perfected shigaraki plus all for
one plus dobby plus all the other
villains adds up to an absolute disaster
for the heroes definitely let me know
what you guys thought of this insane
reveal like yeah i saw it coming and i'm
sure a lot of you guys did too but now
that it's here it is such a game changer
and it completely flips everything we
thought we knew about the current
situation in my opinion the odds are now
heavily stacked in favor of the villains
and the heroes are going to need some
serious plot armor to come out on top in
the end oh and if you made it this far
into the video do me a quick favor and
like and subscribe it really means a lot
and it helps with that youtube algorithm
the chapter then switches focus to our
boy spinner who is getting an important
pep talk from all for one and skeptic
spinner is really concerned about
shigaraki who is still wreathing in pain
and who looks like he's barely clinging
to life at this point but all for one
assures him that everything is going
according to plan and tomuna's recovery
process is going smoothly smoothly
definitely isn't the word that spinner
or anyone else would use to describe
shigaki's grueling recovery process but
as we know all for one is just built
different when spinner asks whether
shigaraki is still himself all for one's
like oh yeah bro for sure don't even
worry about it that is total bs of
course but skeptic conveniently changes
the subject he talks about the fact that
many people with mutant type quirks like
spinner are social outcasts who resent
heroes and the hero society that's
because mutant quirks are quirks that
make the user's body permanently
different from the bodies of the
majority of people so that makes them
stand out and it makes them targets for
discrimination the giant furry girl that
deku saved was a great example of that
she has a mutant type quirk that gives
her a very large stature and animal-like
features this is something that she
can't control she was just born this way
but because this makes her different
from most people she was viewed with
suspicion and mistaken for a villain i'm
sure this was not the first time that
someone was scared of her just because
of her appearance and i'm sure that many
individuals with mutant type quirks
probably face similar situations all the
time because of this people with mutant
quirks are more likely to feel like
outcasts who have been mistreated by
society and as a result many of them
have rebelled against this society
skeptic says that spinner has become a
symbol for these people a sort of hero
for those who are seen as abnormal by
society as a whole with his own mutant
type quirk and his notoriety due to his
affiliation with the league of villains
spinner is the perfect person to rally
all of these disenfranchised mutant
people to the cause of the villains
which would of course make the villains
even stronger and put the heroes into an
even more difficult situation spinner
isn't really interested in this and his
intention was never to be some sort of
leader he was just a guy who was wronged
by the hero society and who believed in
stain's crusade to bring back true
heroism but spinner is no longer just
some guy cosplaying a stain he is now a
powerful symbol in his own right just
like stain was such a powerful symbol
for him spinner says that if it's for
shigaraki's sake then sure he will play
his part in recruiting the mutant quirk
users to their cause and on the very
last page we see a bunch of mutant quirk
users getting together presumably to
meet up with spinner one of these
individuals seems to be that slime
villain from the very first chapter of
the manga so yet again we have another
call back to the beginning of the story
to me this emphasizes yet again that the
mha manga is preparing for an epic
conclusion and that is why the story is
coming full circle the final words that
we see are all for one telling spinner
that anyone can become someone else's
hero meaning that a villain like him can
become a hero to those who are outcasts
from society just like he is and that is
how this chapter ends and honestly this
was a major chapter in terms of the
villain side of things we just learned
that the villains possess the ability to
use a sad man's parade and that they are
recruiting an army of mutant quirk users
this is of course on top of the fact
that the villains already have
overpowered fighters on their side
including all for one awaken shigaraki
dabi and so on when we consider the
situation now including how overextended
the heroes are i think that the odds are
now heavily in the favor of the villains
isabel's plan better be brilliant and he
better make use of aoyama's traitor
reveal to the fullest otherwise the
heroes are in huge trouble with
everything that's happening it really
does bring it home to me that this manga
will be ending soon with all the
callbacks to the first chapter of the
story and the stage being set for a
colossal clash between the heroes and
villains i can't help but think that we
might be just a couple of dozen chapters
away from the end and that is a scary
thought after we've been following this
story for so long how soon do you guys
think that the mha story is going to end
also how do you think that the villains
are ultimately going to use sad man's
parade will they use it to surround and
storm the ua or will they use it in some
other way finally can isabel's plan make
up for all of these villain w's or are
the heroes about to be l plus ratioed by
sad man's parade don't forget to leave
your thoughts down in the comments below
if you guys enjoyed this video and you
want to see more videos in the future
just leave a quick like and of course
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications that is a completely free
way to support the channel and of course
subscribing and hitting the bell is the
only way to make sure that you will
actually see our videos in your
recommended feel free to hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys